I think we're good
[Music]
my name is Andrew ray I host a youtube
cooking show called binging with babish
where I recreate the foods for movies
and television so right now what we're
doing is making buddy's breakfast
dessert pasta from ELF one of the most
important things to me on my show and in
the recreation of movie and TV foods is
rigorous accuracy so even in this case
you know we've got the same syrups we've
got the same sized chocolate chips
marshmallows M&Ms fledged pop-tarts
we're not missing a thing we got to get
this exactly the same as it is in the
movie I'm weird I like eating raw pasta
probably bad for you but so are most of
the most the best things in life like
fried butter this is one of the easiest
dishes to make from my show I would say
and it's a great way to share the
holiday spirit with your friends and
family that's this Christmas it has a
lot of tricks to try and tell when pasta
is ready let's take out a piece
it's not done
[Music]
we got some pasta
I like plating up the pasta by using
tongs or a carving fork twist it up just
plate it up just like that and now it's
time to top it up let's start with a
base of marshmallows with some caramel
sauce some nice swirls on the outside
there it looks fun I'm going to hide the
maple syrup in the pasta chocolate chips
let's introduce some color in the next
shall we it's like one of these bad boys
crumble this over top and there we have
it buddy's breakfast dessert pasta from
ELF I've never given anybody something
that's been so gross this is one of my
bottom five things that have ever made
on the show and I'm excited to see what
they're gonna think of this monstrosity
a lot prettier than it did in the movie
will you lady in the [ __ ] would mean
absolutely not what a petite Beach it's
like so many different levels of sweets
and then you get that hit of noodle
flavor yeah it's almost like nice to
have the pasta so it's not too sweet
buddy's on the feminine he predicted
this turned all the way back in 1990
I'm gonna come out ships should I do
some hand stuff how did he eat it he
just took it with his hand not in it
where I think it was exactly what I
thought it was gonna be yeah a little
better though not gonna a little better
it was actually really good like
honestly I lie a lot in these videos
this is true huge shout-out to babish
for making this possible I feel closer
to Buddy the elf now it was nice to be
able to take something that you've seen
in a film and then make it real and
actually gonna try it
Thank You babish so much if you if
you're ever into it if you ever want to
just call me I'm here booze and with
babish is the next series was up